오늘은 호르무즈 현장 취재로 본 이란의 진짜 속셈에 대해서 이야기를 해볼 건데
제가 현장 취재를 간 건 아니고 현장 취재를 간 미디어가 있어서
거기에서 어떤 얘기를 했는지 좀 볼 거고
저는 이제 한국으로 돌아왔습니다.
제가 유럽 여행을 3월 19일에 출발을 했는데
제가 유럽에서 한국으로 돌아올 때까지는
이 전쟁이 끝나지 않을까라는 생각을 하면서 돌아다녔는데
단방꾼인가? 어쨌든 제 생각대로 되진 않았고요.
여행 얘기는 아마 다음에 영상으로 좀 해보고
오늘의 주인공은 바로 시트리니 리서치입니다.
시트리니 아마 들어보신 분들 있을 거예요.
왜냐하면 한 달 전에 이 회사의 리서치가
2028년 AI 때문에 금융위기가 생길 수도 있다.
이런 글을 내면서 정말 화제였거든요.
그래서 제가 한 달 전에도 관련된 영상을 만들었었고
이게 이제 화제였는데 궁금하신 분들은 한번 보셔도 되고
어쨌든 이 독립계 리서치 회사는
이 회사에서 또 참신한 시도를 했습니다.
요즘에 모든 사람이 궁금해하는 바로 그 호르무즈 해업
호르무즈 해업에서 실제 어떤 일이 벌어지고 있는지를
직접 알아보겠다라고 하면서 현장 취재를 간 거예요.
그래서 그 얘기를 글로 썼고요.
참고로 이게 또 유료예요.
그래서 구독하신 분들만 볼 수가 있는데
제가 직접 원문을 보고 요약을 또 했습니다.
모든 내용을 얘기할 수는 없기 때문에
실제 내용이 궁금하신 분들은
이 원문을 한번 보시고
꼭 찾아보셨으면 좋겠고요.
제가 생략한 내용들이 많습니다.
그래서 이 원문은 제가 고정 댓글에 달아놓을 테니까
궁금하신 분들은 원문을 한번 읽어보시면 되겠습니다.
제한된 정보밖에 없기 때문에
직접 가서 한번 확인을 해야 한다라는 생각으로
현장 취재를 결정을 했고요.
분석가 3호를 파견을 했습니다.
참고로 이분은 아랍어 포함 4개 국어를 구사하시고
샤오미폰인데 이게 이제 폰을 가져갔는데
스마트폰이기도 하고
이게 사진이 엄청 잘 찍힌다고 해요.
샤오미폰도 가지고 갔고
현금 15,000달러를 들고
이분이 이제 두바이로 갔다가
오만을 갔다가 호르무즈 해업으로 갔다라고 보시면 됩니다.
자 구글 지도로 보시면
이분이 이제 두바이로 갔다가
여기서 이제 오만으로 간 거죠.
오만으로 넘어가야 이 호르무즈 해업
북쪽에는 이란이 있죠.
북쪽에는 이란이 있고 남쪽에는 오만이 있고
여기가 이제 호르무즈 해업인데
여기를 이제 오만 땅에서 호르무즈 해업 쪽을
취재한다고 합니다.
그래서 이 호르무즈 해업을 가지고 갔다가
취재를 한 겁니다.
그렇게 보시면 될 것 같아요.
여기서 있었던 일이다 라고 보시면 되고
자 이분에 대해서 이제 익명으로 해서
이분이 도대체 어떤 사람인지는 정확하게 알 수가 없는데
이 분석가 3호가 걸프 지역에 인맥이 좀 있나 봐요.
뭐 알아보도 할 줄 안다고 하니까
원래 이쪽 사람이었을 수도 있을 것 같은데
이 두바이 지역에서 하는 전기 포커 모임에 가서
자신들의 인맥을 통해 정보 수집을 했는데
자 여기서의 네 가지 정도 결론이 있었다고 합니다.
첫 번째 전쟁 기간이 시장의 예상보다
훨씬 장기화될 가능성으로
가능성이 높을 것 같다라고 하고
그리고 이제 여기 있는 사람들이
다음의 타격을 어디 할지를
막 예측하기도 했었다라고 하고
미군의 움직임도 시장에서 나오는 보도보다
훨씬 더 빠르게 병력이 직결되고 있고
자 이란의 공격의 강도 드론의 공격의 빈도
이런 것들이 공식 발표보다 훨씬 더 많다라고 합니다.
그다음에는 오만으로 넘어갔습니다.
그래서 이제 오만으로 넘어가서
오만에서 이란의 밀수꾼들을
만났다고 해요.
이란의 밀수꾼들은
이란 쪽과 오만 쪽을 왔다 갔다 하면서
전자제품이나 담배나 술
이런 것들을 밀수하는 분들인데
이런 분들이랑 대화를 해보니까
분쟁 이후에도 밀수 활동의 감소는 거의 없었다라고 합니다.
다시 말해서
이 이란 혁명수비대의 입장과 맞는 선박들은
문제없이 통과를 한 거고
특정 선박만 선별적으로 공격을 하고 있는
그런 상황으로 보시면 될 것 같아요.
그래서 우리가 생각하는 막 기례를 엄청나게 많이 깔아서
그 누구도 지나갈 수 없게 한 거나
뭐 이런 건 아닌 것 같고
그냥 어떻게 보면 인위적으로
이 해협을 막는 시도를 하고 있다
정도로 보면 될 것 같아요.
자 그리고 또 어부들을 만나가지고
호르무즈 해협 인근에서 활동하고 있는
어부들과 대화를 나눠서 알게 된 것들은
AIS를 완전히 끈 유조선이 하루에
4척에서 5척 정도 통과하고 있으며
실제 수치는 추적 데이터보다 훨씬 높다.
라고 합니다.
분쟁 시작 전 두 주와 비교해
캐시룸 해협 통과량이 급속히 늘고 있다.
호르무즈 해협 통과량이 그냥 급속히 늘고 있다.
라고 보시면 될 것 같아요.
그러니까 현재 공식적으로 발표되는 것보다
더 많은 유조선들이 넘어가고 있는 건
사실으로 볼 수 있을 것 같고
군함이 아닌 민간선과 어선에 대해서도
드론 공격이 발생하고 있는데
이는 어디에도 나오지 않는다.
라고 하고
그리스 다이나컴 소속 유조선 한 척이
해협 한 가운데를 전속력으로 가로지르는데
보통은 조심히 지나가는 배들은
오만 해안선에 바짝 붙어서 지나가는데
이 배만 뭔가 당당하게 중앙을 지나가는 걸로 봐서는
협상을 완료한 것 같다.
라고 하고 있고요.
어떤 통과 어떤 선박들이
현재 이란과 어느 정도 이야기가 돼서 통과를 한 건지
이것도 뭐 그냥 이분이 들은 얘기입니다.
뭐 공식적인 발표까지는 아니고
이분이 직접 가서 들은 이야기에 따르면
인도 말레이시아 일본 그리스 프랑스
어
오만 터키 중국 등이 호르무즈
해협을 건너가고 있다라는 얘기가 있습니다.
이쪽 선박들이 근데 이 AIS
일종의 그러니까 자기 자신의 위치를 알리는
장치를 끄고 통과한 거기 때문에
이제 통계에 잡히는 것보다 더 적은 상황인 거죠.
통계에 잡히는 것보다 더 많이 통과하고 있다라는 거고요.
4월 2일 그러니까 현지 특파원이 있었던 4월 2일 기준으로는
무려 15척이나 호르무즈 해협을 통과했고
직전 2주
평균이 하루 2척에서 5척이었으니까 급격한 증가로 볼 수가 있다라고 하고요.
통행허가 절차에 대해서도 이제 얘기를 들었다라고 해요.
그래서 통행허가 절차가 어떻게 되냐면 특정 선조와 국가가 통과를 희망을 하면
브로커를 접촉을 하고요.
이 브로커를 통해서 이란 혁명수비대 쪽에서 심사를 한다라고 합니다.
그래서 미국과 뭔가 연관이 얼마나 되어 있는지를 정밀하게 확인을 한다라고 하고요.
그래서 대금을 납부를 하는 데에 대해서는
이 돈을 낼 때는 현금이나 암호화폐를 통해서 내기도 하는데
재미있었던 거는 시장에서는 블룸버그 같은 곳에서는 현금이나 암호화폐 위주로 얘기를 했는데
사람들이 또 간과했던 포인트 중에 하나가 자산 해제라는 포인트가 있습니다.
자 이 자산 해제라는 건 뭐냐면 어떤 나라가 이란과 협상했을 때 우리 배를 통과시켜줘 라고 하면
이제 돈 달라고 하는 게 아니라 이란이 원래 받아야 되는 돈들 중에 그게 계좌가 없어서
자 이 자산 해제라는 건 뭐냐면 어떤 나라가 이란과 협상했을 때 우리 배를 통과시켜줘 라고 하면 이제 돈 달라고 하는 게 아니라 이란이 원래 받아야 되는 돈들 중에 그게 계좌가 없어서
동결된 계좌들이 있거든요.
미국이 이란을 제재하면서 이란에게 줘야 되는 돈들이 은행에 동결되어 있는 국가들이 좀 있는데
그렇게 동결된 이란의 자산들을 해제해서 이란이 가져가게 하는 그런 형태도 호르무즈 해업을 통과할 때 많이 사용된다라고 합니다.
한국도 제가 알기로 일부 이란의 자산을 동결하고 있는 걸로 알고 있는데 한국도 이걸 협상 카드로 쓸 수 있지 않나 라는 생각이 조금 들었고
어쨌든 이렇게 대금을 납부하고 나면 이제 확인 코드를 수령하고 이렇게 호르무즈 해업을 통과한다라고 하고요.
그 외에도 상당히 흥미로웠던 부분들은 어쨌든 납부 방식이 외교적 자산 해제 제가 방금 말씀드린 부분 이게 생각보다 시장에 많이 알려지지 않았다라는 거고요.
그리고 선장들이랑 또 얘기를 해보니까 선장들이 보험 때문에 우리가 호르무즈 해업을 건너가지 않는다 이렇게 얘기를 하지만 사실 보험보다는
더 큰 부분이 바로 배를 잃고 싶지 않은 부분이 더 크다고 해요.
지금 배를 일단 유조선을 수급하는 게 현재 상당히 어려운 상태거든요.
유조선을 보험료를 받는다고 해도 이 배값을 전부 다 받는다고 해도 지금 이 유조선을 굴리는 게 훨씬 더 가치가 큰 상황이라
금전적인 손실이 어마어마하다라는 거죠.
그래서 저자가 생각하는 예상 시나리오는 세 가지 정도가 있습니다.
어떤 시나리오가 있냐면 첫 번째 시나리오는 미국이 그들이 말하는
대로 이란을 석기시대로 만들어 버리는 거죠.
이건 이란한테 최악의 시나리오입니다.
미국이 정말 박살 낸다면 이란한테 최악이고 호르무즈 해업은 결국 해제가 되겠죠.
두 번째 시나리오는 이란에게 최선인 시나리오인데 분쟁이 길어지고 비용이 커져서 결국에 협상으로 마무리가 되는데
더 나아가서 이 호르무즈 해업이 이란이 원하는 형태로 해업에 대한 관리 권리까지 인정이 되는 그런 방향입니다.
이런 경우에는 이란에게 최선이 되겠죠.
이란이 제일 원하는 방향이 될 것 같고.
3번 시나리오는 바로 어정쩡한 중간 상태인데 어떻게 보면 지금의 상황 그냥 지속이 되는 그런 상태가 예상 시나리오 중에 세 가지로 꼽았고요.
그래서 저자가 느낀 점은 이란이 합리적이고 예측 가능하게 행동한다라는 것을 많이 느꼈다고 해요.
왜냐하면 허가를 받은 선박 중에 단 한 척도 공격받지 않았거든요.
많은 사람들이 걱정하는 게 이란이 뭔가 지금 지도자도 죽고 전도자도.
명령 전달 체계가 작동하지 않고 있다.
이런 얘기를 했지만 사실은 오히려 지금까지 허가를 받은 선박 중에 한 척도 공격받지 않았다는 것은 명확한 신호체계가 작동하고 있다고 볼 수가 있는 것 같고요.
그리고 이 시트리니 리서치에서는 이런 매매를 해보면 어떨까.
이런 걸 사라 이렇게 얘기를 합니다.
그런데 제가 이런 걸 다 말씀드리는 게 여기가 유료 리서치 회사인데 제가 여기 있는 내용을 전부 다 말하는 게 옳지 않은 것 같아요.
그래서 흥미로운 거 몇 가지 갖고 와봤는데요.
일단은 원유 스프레드를 좀 사라.
그러니까 이게 무슨 말이냐면 원유 선물 근월은 고평가됐고 원월은 저평가됐다는 얘기예요.
그러니까 이게 지금 제가 말을 좀 어렵게 말했는데 조금 더 설명을 제가 그냥 붙여만 보자면
이 원유 선물이란 게 결국 원유가 미래에 어떤 가격에 있을 거냐라는 거를 이제 시장에서 판단을 한 건데
지금 시장에서 생각하는 가격은 원유가 단기적으로만 엄청 올랐다가 곧 정상화가 될 건데요.
이런 거다라고 시장에서 생각을 하지만 시트리니는 정상화라는 개념 자체가 틀렸다라고 보고
이란의 이제 수금소 모델 그러니까 이란이 이제 돈을 받는다는 거죠.
지나가는 선박들한테 그렇게 이란이 수금소 모델을 하고 그것이 정착이 되면
영구적인 리스크 프리미엄이 원유 가격에 붙으면서 유가가 높은 상태가 될 거다라는 겁니다.
그러니까 근월은 쇼트하고 오히려 원월을 롱해야 되는 그런 상황이다라는 거죠.
그리고 또 저자가 추천한 매매 중에 하나가 이거 좀 슬퍼가지고 갖고 왔는데
일본은 롱하고 한국은 쇼타라는 거예요. 왜 그러냐.
같은 에너지 취약성을 갖고 있는데 이란과 외교적으로 더 유연하게 접근할 수 있는 국가와
그렇지 못한 국가 사이에서 결과가 갈릴 거라는 거예요.
그래서 한국은 한미동맹이라는 구조상 이란과 독자 협상하기가 일본보다도 훨씬 어렵다라는 거예요.
그래서 아까도 보여드렸지만 호르무즈 통과국 중에 일본이 곧 추가가 될 거다 이런 얘기가 있어요.
그래서 일본은 뭔가 이란 측과 대화를 하고 있는 듯하다라고 시트리니 리서치에서는 얘기를 하고 있는데
한국은 미국과 훨씬 더 친하다 보니까 이게 어려울 거다 그런 얘기를 하고 있습니다.
우리나라에 테란 로드 있는데 이거 너무한 거 아닌가 이런 생각도 들고
그리고 진짜 한국이 원유를 정제하는 기술이니까요.
이 세계에서 엄청난 수준이기 때문에 또 한국으로 사실 또 원유가 와야 이 모든 또 문제들이 해결될 수가 있는데
어쨌든 이들의 이 예측은 좀 틀렸으면 하는 바람이 저는 좀 있고요.
그리고 이 보고서의 결론은 다극화 세계의 본격적인 시작이 될 거다라는 거예요.
예전까지는 미국이 세계의 경찰 노릇을 했잖아요.
그래서 문제가 있으면 해결을 하고 자기 나름대로 정의에 입각해서 문제를 해결하고 질서를 정해줬는데
이제는 미국의 태도가 어땠습니까?
프랑스, 그리스, 일본 알아서 미국의 동맹들도 알아서 이란과 직접 협상해서 통행권을 확보하고 있습니다.
그러니까 이제 다극화된 지구촌이 되어가고 있다는 거예요.
그래서 예전 같으면 상상도 할 수 없는 거죠.
그러니까 각자 도생의 시대가 됐다라는 겁니다.
그래서 이제는 이분법적으로 호르무즈가 닫혔느니 호르무즈가 폐쇄됐느니 전쟁이느니 전쟁이 아니느니 이런 식으로 생각하지 말고
복잡한 상황들이 동시에 공존한다라는 마인드로 접근을 해야 한다라는 겁니다.
이 보고서의 결론은 진짜 기회, 알파죠.
이 알파는 복잡성에서 나온다.
완전 봉쇄도 아니고 완전 정상화도 아니기 때문에
이 중간 상태가 만드는 가격의 비효율을 이용해라라는 게 이 보고서의 결론입니다.
계속 말씀드렸지만 제가 생략한 내용이 매우 많아서 원문이 궁금하신 분들은 고정 댓글을 참고해서 보시고요.
이거 참고로 유료입니다.
그래서 무료인 부분이 있는데 무료인 부분은 내용이 거의 없어요.
그래서 전문은 훨씬 더 내용이 많고요.
참고로 뒷광고 절대 아닙니다.
그냥 제가 흥미로워서 갖고 와봤고요.
그리고 제 생각을 좀 한 스푼만 얹어보자면 계속 틀렸던 저의 생각을 한 스푼 얹어보자면
일하는 장기전으로 끌고 갈 의지가 이 보고서만 봤을 때는 매우 강력해 보입니다.
저는 장기전으로 끌고 갈 의지가 그렇게 약할 거라고 생각을 했는데
이 보고서를 본 다음에는 조금 생각이 바뀌었습니다. 저도.
그래서 그게 좀 나쁜 뉴스인 것 같고요.
그나마 제가 이 보고서를 보면서 생각하는 좀 좋은 뉴스는
저는 만약에 호르무즈 회업이 장기 봉쇄가 되면 정말 무슨 아비규환의 상황
어쨌든 전 지구촌이 다 정말 지옥으로 가는 그런 상황이 될 거라고 생각했는데
그것보다는 지금 이란도 어쨌든 중간에서 통행료를 받으려고 하니까
그나마 덜 나쁜 거 아닌가? 좀 끔찍한 지옥까지는 아닐 것 같다.
이 전쟁이 길어지더라도 끔찍한 지옥은 아닐 수도 있을 것 같다라는
이란의 생각처럼은요.
그냥 장기적으로 끌고 가도 괜찮을 수도 있을 것 같다라는 생각도 조금 들었지만
뭐 이런 얘기를 해봤자 결국에 전쟁이 좀 해결이 돼야 되는데
오늘도 계속 이런저런 뉴스 치고받고 있어가지고
그것도 조금 정리가 되면 영상으로 만들어 볼 건데
오늘 조금 그래도 최근에 제가 봤던 이란 관련된 내용 중에서 흥미로워서 한번 갖고 와 봤습니다.
저는 투자와 관련된 블로그 하고 있고 투자와 관련된 인스타그램 하고 있으니까
궁금하신 분들은 고정 댓글 설명란 참고 부탁드립니다. 감사합니다.